[Music]
yeah evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation stories are
something we use something we tell a lot
of the time to understand the world
we've been doing this for a long time
we'll probably keep doing it for a long
time you saw on the screen Danny Hillis
--is a narrative version of thinking
about the 10,000 hour clock and we're
actually building a 10,000 year clock
physically in Texas our speaker tonight
is a prolific writer this is Sandman
Volume one and he's also a prolific
reader grew up basically in libraries he
says and libraries are these time
spanning places where stories and other
such things collect and as a writer he's
unusually transparent about being a
writer about the writing about stories
and we can think of no one better to
talk about the long now question how
exactly do stories last Neil Gaiman
[Music]
[Music]
many many years ago I remember defining
art as something you could use
successfully to stun a burglar and was
very proud of myself for having written
enough sandman to do that
watching Stuart drop it on the stage I
did actually try and persuade DC Comics
to do the one volume Sandman and failed
because apparently bookbinding is not up
to the task and also it might kill the
poor burglar so Thank You Stuart
thank you to the long now foundation
thank you to everybody who's invited me
to come and talk particularly Danny
Hillis who is not here Thank You Danny I
want to talk about stories the first
emperor of China died 2,300 years ago he
did a lot of very important things in
China things they still talk about for
example he regularized the distance
between the wheels of cards now this may
not seem an incredibly important thing
to you how how far apart your cart
wheels are but when you realize that all
carts and carriages essentially traveled
in the ruts in roads in muddy roads that
at some point would be mud and then they
would dry out and you're traveling in
ruts
standardizing the distance of your
wheels meant that you could travel from
one end of China to the other a wheeled
conveyance could go from one end of that
vast empire to the other end he did a
lot of other things to was absolutely
the most powerful man in the world and
like many such powerful men he became
obsessed with immortality with not dying
ever under any circumstances his
unfortunate failure to achieve success
in this by the usual magical and
alchemical roots resulted in his death
they actually tried covering up his
death for a while they sent his body
home in a carriage filled with rotting
fish to mask the smell-- and claim that
the smell was the fish and he was
rapidly interred in a tomb that he had
been building for quite a bit of his
life the location of the tomb was soon
lost and pretty soon there were only
stories stories about his tomb stories
that said the tomb contained
unimaginable treasures including a
terracotta army of soldiers and ships
that floated on seas of underground
mercury they built whole lakes of
mercury and put ships on them
there was another king whose name we do
not know his likeness was carved in
marble and placed on a marble plinth to
last forever and the reason why we do
not know his name is his name was carved
into the marble on the base of the
plinth but after a few hundred years the
marble peeled away and was lost
leaving the granite on the plinth with
the name of the sculptor carved into it
so we know who did it the oldest forms
of life around right now if we are to
believe Wikipedia are probably trees and
the oldest tree that we know of a Great
Basin that Bristlecone pine in northern
california is five thousand and sixty
four years old just quite old when you
stop to think about it five thousand 64
years life again according to Wikipedia
you can see why I did my research on
this is the condition that distinguishes
animals and plants from inorganic matter
we are told which definitely
disqualifies stories but then we
discover that it includes the capacity
for growth reproduction functional
activity and continual change preceding
death
so animals animals live at the outside
300 years really long-lived ones trees
really long-lived once again four to
five thousand years the stories can live
longer than that and we know because we
have stories that go back longer than
that there are Native American stories
from the Pacific Northwest that tell a
forbidden love between a woman of
astonishing beauty and a young man and
of how their love was punished of how
the earth rumbled of the black snow that
came out from the mountaintop and then
how the top of the mountain the King
fire killing a great many people only to
be stopped when the young woman was
pushed in to the flames and it's a story
that survives and was collected first in
the 1920s and it survived because it
contains elements that people love to
tell and to retell forbidden love tragic
death but the story itself tells us a
lot of other things it tells us most
importantly that those mountains that
you're looking at those great big
mountains that seem like they must have
been there forever are not permanent
things it tells us that volcanoes can
happen it tells you of the early warning
systems
the idea that the ground can shake that
ash will fall and if you are passing on
a story generation to generation and you
want that information to travel
you really have probably about three
generations of passing it on as pure
information you can say to your children
and to your grandchildren you know those
mountains over there that look kind of
solid well they aren't and ash can fall
the ground can shake and they will turn
to flame and and this hot flaming Rocky
stuff will come out of them and your
grandson may believe this but his
grandson when he says you know my
grandfather told me it's gonna go yeah
really
it's a mountain and his grandson is
gonna go you people are mad no I'm not
passing on that story but if the story
has things that make it sweet around it
things that make it fun to pass on
things that make it pleasurable to tell
in this case beautiful women forbidden
love
grumpy gods
somebody being sacrificed into a volcano
people get them thrown into volcanoes it
always works it is it is you know in the
giant list of things that we authors
have tricks that never fail right after
somebody comes through the door with a
gun is throw somebody into a volcano
the tale of two brothers is the story
dates back about 2,000 BC to SETI the
second setting it was recorded on
papyrus by a scribe about 4000 years ago
the story centers around two brothers
UNPO the elder who is married looks
after the younger buttah
the brothers work together farming land
raising cattle one day um whose wife
attempts to seduce butter but he rejects
her advances she then tells her husband
that his brother tried to seduce her and
um puh obviously very sensibly tries to
kill his brother who flees prays to be
saved the god save him by creating a
crocodile-infested lake between him and
his brother across which barter explains
his side of the story and to emphasize
his sincerity cuts off his genitalia
throws him into the water and they are
eaten by a catfish
[Music]
it's only just begun barter then says
that he is going to go to the valley of
the cedar where he will place his heart
on the top of the blossom of a cedar
tree so if it's cut down I'm who will be
able to find it and allow bata to become
alive again and he gives um puh a he
taught me he tells him that if ever his
bier mysteriously Frost's he knows to
come and hunt down his brother and then
hump who goes home kills his wife there
was a theme in these things and it's not
particularly cheerful meanwhile bata has
a new life for himself and he has a wife
a new wife created for him by the gods
and because she is divine Pharaoh falls
in love with her and she tells the
Pharaoh to go and cut down the tree
how much barter has his heart and butter
dies and then the beer gets frothy and
um puh goes off and there's all sorts of
fun barter keeps getting resurrected
first is a bull and they murdered the
ball and then two drops of blood get
rescued from the ball and they become
trees and butter in the form of a tree
you know appeals to his wife but she
goes she goes back to the the Pharaoh
and she says look let's make furniture
those trees that as they are making
furniture a splinter enters her mouth
impregnating her and thus her son is her
resurrected husband and becomes Crown
Prince and appoints his brother as his
co ruler and it's all fun and games in
ancient Egypt
and the reason I've told you that story
it's actually it's a 4,000 year old
story that's a long time you think about
4,000 years and a couple of years ago I
was chatting to an Egyptologist and she
was telling me about how they were on an
archeological dig with the locals in
Egypt helping them as the support team
and they started telling stories around
the campfire and the oldest man told
them that he would tell them a story
that he heard from his father and he
began to tell them the tale of two
brothers named Dan pou and bata and she
realized she was hearing the oral
version of something that was written
down 4000 years ago that have been told
as a story 4000 years that's right up
there with the trees
a story's alive can they be considered
alive what was our list growth
reproduction functional activity and
continual change the stories grow pretty
obviously anybody who has ever heard a
joke
being passed on from one person to
another knows that they can grow they
can change can stories reproduce well
yeah not spontaneously obviously they
tend to need people as vectors we are
the media in which they reproduce we are
their petri dishes but they can and they
do stories grow sometimes they shrink
they reproduce they inspire other
stories and of course if they do not
change stories die it's fascinating
going back and looking through old fairy
tales old oral tradition stories and
watching the ones that just do not get
told anymore there is nothing about them
that impels people to say let me tell
you the story where as stories sometimes
will simply enter the oral tradition and
sometimes stories will find they would
they were mutate they will change just a
little and they will wind up with an
evolutionary advantage over other
similar stories
I've been told this isn't true but damn
it's a good story so I'm going to tell
it to you anyway in a story about
stories it seems only fair the story of
Cinderella Cinderella probably began in
China there are there are definitely
there is definitely evidence that it may
have begun in China there are very few
Western cultures in which having
incredibly small feet was actually
deemed a mark of obvious princess wood
there is a case to be made he said
rather nervously because maybe there
isn't somebody sent me hi somebody heard
me talking about this recently and sent
me a thing completely disproving it and
I went no it's too beautiful but one of
the most significant things about
Cinderella is the glass slippers they're
probably the most memorable bit of
Cinderella the idea of slippers made of
glass there is a theory that originally
those slippers might have been fur which
in French is their Vai R and that threw
a homonym ik shift they became their ve
double r e and slipped from fur slippers
which sound fairly regular two glass
slippers which are gloriously unlikely
and stick in the memory and give the
story of Cinderella a tiny evolutionary
advantage over all the stories that are
kind of like Cinderella of which there
are hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
and yet Cinderella is the one that we
remember and people go oh well that's
Disney
and you know actually it's not I mean if
one of the things that fascinates me is
that there are places where Disney would
take an old story a fairy tale and try
and retell it and bump into some of the
problems inherent in the actual story
they were they were telling for example
Sleeping Beauty the best thing about
Sleeping Beauty is she falls asleep for
a hundred years and during that hundred
years thorns grow up around the castle
and eventually after a hundred years a
prince hacks his way in snog her and
everybody wakes up
Disney ran into obvious problems with
that which is it's really hard to start
a story and then have hundred you know a
solid hundred years your if you if she
meets a prince early on in the film he
will be dead it's not gonna be him so
they made it an afternoon you go back
and watch Sleeping Beauty they fall
asleep
the ones grow up prince gallops in
kisses her everybody wakes up they
barely had a nap
but that hasn't lasted that's not the
way people will tell the story although
of course Sleeping Beauty has originally
told in a lot of the versions we have
was actually just a prelude it was where
a story began Sleeping Beauty was the
intro to the real story which is she
goes home with the prince and his mother
is appalling and does all the things
that appalling mother-in-law's do vision
to wit try and frame her daughter for
having killed and even her children and
that was the exciting bit that was that
was where the story went but that bit
kind of faded it it died the story
itself mutated and people seemed
perfectly happy to have the happily ever
after happen there happen after after
the waking up
stories have creators every story begins
at some point with an act of imagining
scientists who are not in other ways
fanciful get reinvented when it comes to
the origins of stories I've read
otherwise sensible papers articles and
books which assume suddenly the
existence of a communal undermined yours
mine
everybody in histories and stories
sitting deep in their already fully
formed like jewels in a deep mine the
idea of an individual storyteller is
actually discouraged as it's the idea
that somebody plotted a story stories
can only be seen in this context as
being passed on from one person to
another with details accreting or being
lost on the way as they change and some
people who wrote about stories went to
even stranger places
Perik states with certainty that in any
story any early old story in any
folktale in which a character falls
asleep we know that this story was
originally a dream and because primitive
humans were unable to tell the
difference between waking and sleeping
they would have woken up with the story
in their heads produced on some magical
unconscious level I remember reading
that story and being absolutely
fascinated by it have you ever tried to
tell someone
even a friendly sympathetic even as
someone who loves you
a dream of yours the next morning have
you ever watched their eyes glaze over
watch them slowly lose the ability to
feign interest probably along with the
will to live even as you start to
suspect that threads of narrative
causality that seemed obvious on waking
don't exist you're saying well then we
were back in my old school which was a
kind of castle and in the toilets there
was a tree so we climbed it and you
realized that no matter how gripping it
was for you while it was going on it is
not going to be gripping by lunchtime
pictures I think may have been a way of
transmitting stories the drawings on
cave walls but we assume are acts of
worship or of sympathetic magic intended
to bring hunters luck and good kills
I keep wondering if actually they're
just ways of telling stories we came
over that Ridge and we saw a herd of
wooly Bisons
and I wondered that because people tell
stories
it's an enormous part of what makes us
human we will do an awful lot for
stories we will endure a lot for stories
and stories in their turn like some kind
of symbol
help us endure and make sense of our
lives a lot of stories do appear to
begin as intrinsic to religions and
belief systems they a lot of the ones we
have have gods or goddesses in them they
teach us how the world exists they teach
us the rules of living in the world but
they also have to come in an attractive
enough package that we take pleasure
from them and we want to help them
propagate human beings appreciate human
beings are hard-wired to appreciate
simile and metaphor for those of you who
are incredibly relieved to no longer be
at school and who are pretty sure you
know the difference between the two it's
the ass
simile is as beautiful as an airport
that was Douglas Adams this example of a
simile but nobody has ever used he said
nobody ever says as beautiful it was as
beautiful as an airport and a metaphor
is when you say that something is
something else to help you understand it
better
the moon is a ghostly galleon tossed
upon stormy seas and isn't it's not what
the moon is it's a big lump of rock in
the sky not a ghostly galleon but
it is our capacity to use simile and use
metaphor that I think allows us to
understand and appreciate the best
things of our stories because people can
have two contradictory things going on
in their heads at the same time and
those contradictory things are these a
story is a lie her story is true stories
let us make no bones about it
a lies they didn't really happen
Once Upon a Time is a code for I am
about to lie to you for that matter this
really happened to a friend of someone I
know is also code for I'm lying to you
but I believe there is a possibility
that this might actually have happened
to somebody somewhere somehow the act of
reading a story or listening to a story
is the act of knowing you are being lied
to but it's a true thing you have walked
with the people in the story you've
looked out through their eyes you know
what they believe you walk with them and
by walking with them you have left your
own reality and entered theirs and that
gives us something very strange because
information in a story is something that
you can access as real information you
can access it as if
you have experienced it you can use it
and then you can pass it on there's
meant to be a break and a huge
difference between the oral tradition of
storytelling in the written tradition of
storytelling I'm not as convinced people
tell each other stories there's a lovely
example from the 1920s of folklorists
collecting a story that have been told
that had been written in the 1890s by a
lady named Lucy Clifford and she'd
written a story called the new mother
and it was collected under the name of
the pair drum and what was great is
they'd left out all of the bad writing
all of the weirdness of the prose they
just got down to the story but they kept
the oddest bits of the story the fact
that it had happened this weird story
had happened to two children named
turkey and blue eyes that got remembered
that stayed in the oral tradition
there's a story I like to tell because
it changed me and stories should change
you good stories should change you and
this story this isn't mine this is a
story of something that happened to my
cousin Helen she's 97 and she was in
Poland during the war and was the ghetto
for some of the war she was a Holocaust
survivor a remarkable woman and a few
years ago she started telling me the
story of how in the ghetto they were not
allowed books if you had a book somebody
could well not just somebody the Nazis
could put a gun to your head and pull
the trigger
books were forbidden and she used to
teach under the pretense of having a
sewing class of doing sewing she would
actually teach a class about 20 little
girls and they would come in for an hour
a day and she would teach them maths
she keeps the Polish she teach them
grammar and one day somebody slipped her
a polish translation of Margaret
Mitchell's novel Gone with the Wind and
Helen stayed up she blacked out her
window so she could stay up an extra
hour and she read a chapter I've gone
with the wind and when the girls came in
the next day instead of teaching them
she told them what happened in the book
and each night she'd stay up and each
day she told them the story and I said
why why would he risk death for a story
and she said because for an hour every
day those girls weren't in the ghetto
they were in the American South they
were having they were having adventures
they got away
I think four out of those 20 girls
survived the war and she told me how
when she was an old woman she found one
of them who was also an old woman and
they got together and called each other
by names in Gone with the Wind the names
of characters and I thought you know we
decry too easily
writers what we do has being kind of
trivial the creation of stories as being
a trivial thing but the magic of
escapist fiction and the thing I think
that some people miss I think I missed
is that it can actually offer you a
genuine escape from a bad place and in
the process of escaping it can furnish
you with armor with knowledge with
weapons with tools you can take back
into your life to help make it better I
doubt there's anybody who loves reading
who hasn't at some point gone to a book
sometimes when they're young as a means
of escaping from an otherwise
intolerable situation and you know what
it's a real escape and when you come
back you come back better armed than
when you left Helens story is a true
story and this is what we learn from it
that stories are worth risking your life
for they're worth dying for
written stories and oral stories both
offer escape escape from somewhere
escape to somewhere I mentioned Douglas
Adams before Douglass understood media
understood change he essentially
described the first ebooks long before
most commuter trains were filled with
people reading on them and he also
correctly perceived why even though most
commuter trains are a hundred percent
people with ebooks there will always be
physical books and a healthy market for
physical books because Douglas told me
books of sharks I remember saying to him
I have no idea what that means
he said it incredibly confidently simple
books of sharks it's like no I have no
idea what you're talking about
and he said well what you have to
understand is that there were sharks
back when there were dinosaurs in many
cases before there were dinosaurs there
were sharks and now there are sharks and
the reason that there are still sharks
hundreds of millions after the first
sharks of years after the first shots
turned up is that nothing has turned up
that is better at being a shark than a
shark is
[Applause]
ebooks are absolutely fantastic at being
several books in the newspaper they're
really good portable bookshelves that's
why they're great on trains but books
are much better at being books you can
drop them I can guarantee that copy of
the first sandman omnibus still works
[Applause]
but stories aren't books books are
simply one of the many storage
mechanisms in which stories can be kept
and obviously people one of the other
storage mechanisms stories change the
professions and the media that we use to
store and record and transmit stories
will change not long ago the people who
stored and transmitted information were
stonemasons now not so much
unless we want the information to last
paper or solar-powered digital
headstones may be a thing but a big lump
of granite is pretty much forever
as individuals we are cut off from
humanity as individuals we are naked we
do not even know which plants will kill
us without the mess of human knowledge
accumulated over millennia to boy us up
we are in big trouble with it we are
warm fed we have popcorn we are sitting
in comfortable seats and we are capable
of arguing with each other about really
stupid things on the internet that's
because we have stories it's because we
have information in 1984 a man whose
name I don't know how to pronounce
I think it's thomas sebeok wrote a
report for the department of energy he
was asked to create a report because
they had a problem what to do with
nuclear waste repositories
they needed to devise a method of
warning future generations not to mine
or drill at that site unless they're
aware of the consequences of their
actions and because the stuff that they
would be putting in these nuclear waste
repositories had a half-life of 10,000
years they needed to figure out ways to
get information to last for 10,000 years
and they started by looking at all you
can write you can write things but
trouble with writing things that's
writing things lasts a certain amount of
time but anyone here who's actually
tried to read Beowulf in the original
knows that that only takes you so far
language changes words change meaning
you know you could write that something
is wicked you could warn that this is
like the bomb
and a generation could somehow come
along and go wicked the bomb
we got cool stuff in there you could it
could happen
inconceivable I know but language
changes and if language is changing what
about pictographic what if you put a big
scale up and said oh point it out I'm
gonna call him Tom because I know how
that's pronounced Tom pointed out that
even a scowl means different things in
different cultures some cultures might
go ah skull symbol of warning some might
go symbol of fantastic candy days this
is the place where the good stuff is
what he actually came up with I'm gonna
read this because I love it he said that
the the the the prime recommendation of
the human interference task force of the
Department of Energy was that
information be launched and artificially
passed on into the short-term and
long-term future with the supplementary
aid of folkloristic devices in
particular a combination of an
artificially created and nurtured ritual
and legend the most positive aspect of
such a procedure is it need not be
geographically localized or timed to any
one language and culture so the
uninitiated would be steered away from
the hazardous site for reasons other
than the scientific knowledge of the
possibility of radiation and its
implications essentially the reason
would be accumulated superstition to
shun a certain area permanently a ritual
with the legend retold year by year with
presumably slight variation
the actual quote truth would be
entrusted exclusively to what we might
call for dramatic emphasis and atomic
priesthood there is a commission of
knowledgeable physicists experts in
radiation sickness anthropologists and
whatever additional expertise may be
called for in the future
membership in this priesthood would be
they would pick themselves and the best
mechanism for doing this he says is at
present unclear folklore specialists
that they've consulted say they know of
no precedent nor could they think of a
parallel situation except the well-known
but ineffectual curses associated with
the burial sites of some Egyptian
pharaohs which didn't deter greedy grave
robbers from digging for hidden treasure
which is true up to a point the first
emperor of China died over 2,000 years
ago and the site of his tomb was lost
very intentionally lost you know he
killed anybody who knew where it was it
was a magnificent act of tomb losing
and then one day in a field in China
somebody unearthed a terracotta warrior
and then they found another one and they
excavated the Warriors and archeologists
worked out very quickly where the actual
mausoleum had to be but the stories that
have come down to us 2300 years after
the emperor of China had died now became
a warning remember those links of
mercury that stuff is really poisonous
it doesn't even have a half-life it's
just there as terry pratchett once said
radiation is 10,000 years but arsenic is
forever
and so they didn't immediately start
digging instead they checked confirmed
the presence incredibly high quantities
of mercury and have been figuring out
what to do ever since and when they
figure out how to get in there without
dying they will start excavating the
long now and the clock of the long now
is about planning for the long term and
thinking in the long term in a world in
which people appear to be thinking in
the shorter and shorter term not even
necessarily at this point about things
that will take them to the end of their
lifetime which at least at one point you
would have thought people go WOW you
know I'll be dead before that's a
problem looking around now at the mess
that we're making of things on this
planet you want to go to people you know
actually you won't be you will still be
around we could run out of water you'll
be here having to figure out what to do
with no water what to do when the oceans
are screwed up what to do when Twitter
finally becomes sentient
Tom servo concluded you couldn't
actually create a story that would last
10,000 years you could only create a
story that would last for three
generations for ourselves for our
children and for their children but what
we can do I think is try and create
stories that are interesting enough and
important enough but our grandchildren
might want to tell those stories to
their grandchildren because that's the
purpose of stories it's what they're for
they make life worth living and
sometimes they keep us alive
[Applause]
sorry you know Danny Hillis her friend
thinks that humanity is in a kind of
transition now from one narrative to
another and there's some of the
confusion we have is that the narrative
that he thinks it's been going on for a
long time is man conquers nature we
basically take on all the difficulties
of natural world and one by one after
them and so we talk now about the end
throught the scene and if that's in and
we see the downside of mastering nature
and getting into some of the problems
you mentioned so he thinks we're working
up on another narrative that doesn't
have the problems that emerge from the
last minute but is equally compelling
and it gives the kind of meaning that
you talk about you have any sense of one
what that transition what a transition
from one grand narrative to another is
about and do you have any sense of what
narrative wants to emerge what a great
question
I think that for me it's much more of
the idea of going back and I think it's
partly about the the narrative that
we're in now feels like a narrative
defined by by the Alvin Toffler future
shock mm-hmm idea the idea that things
are just changing so rapidly that we are
all we're scrambling to catch up we're
scrambling to stay in the present if you
stop paying attention you will be swept
back in time it's it's wonderful right
now talking to people about telephone
use I heard somebody say
last night use the phrase of course I'm
of the generation where you could just
telephone somebody call them make a
voice call you didn't have to text them
to let them know you were going to be
calling them right and I thought I'm not
that generation that's that's it the you
know might my daughter Maddie who I can
embarrass just by acknowledging her
existence from this stage I'm at is her
telephone her phone is something that
the only people who ever actually phone
her to talk on it is me and her mum it
is a device that is used for a thousand
things and that peculiarly parents used
to call you I love that I love the idea
that I am now some kind of weird fossil
I'm like my mum's friends who would
write thank-you letters if you and and
you know in the 1970s I'm going why I
was at your house yesterday why have you
written a thank-you letter it's it's it
seems so peculiar it seemed like a
remnant of of a Victorian time it seemed
like a remnant of something um the idea
that you're getting swept up and moving
forward and the things are changing so
fast and you know the lovely thing about
for me about coming to the Bay Area is
there are people who will use phrases
like the singularity and actually mean
it
like it's not even ironic but you want
to be able to but for me the the Danny
narrative is actually not a narrative of
moving forward it's just taking taking a
step back taking the long view going
look it actually doesn't matter what you
do with your phone and it doesn't matter
that everybody here who is of the
generation that knows you have to text
before you would make a voice call which
why would you do that that they in their
turn are going to turn around in eight
years time and say to people but why do
I have to send them a photograph of my
genitals before I talked about people
how can you trust anybody who has sent
you a photo of their genitalia and you
know I'm just in a generation where
you've got to know somebody first before
you introduce your genitalia and they
don't well you're old you know and it's
gonna be a whole kind of you know that
sorry Mary um you know that things are
going to keep changing and that is the
only constant except that there are
things that don't change and there are
people and there is this planet and
we're on it
and we had better you know for me but
the whole thing of the clock of the long
now and of the long now is just try and
think in big chunks because at the
moment that you're trying to think in a
10,000 year chunk you go you know if if
we use all that stuff up there won't be
any which is kind of one of those
moments of horrible realization I
remember writing a book years ago called
called Good Omens with Terry Pratchett
and and we had a little rant in there
about the idea of the afterlife of
telling people that you know it all gets
sorted out in heaven and we're saying
actually you know its reeyou SFIL to
point people at the fact that you are
here right now on this planet and if you
kill whales and you've got dead whales
if you kill all the whales you don't
have any whales and that's nobody's
going to come in and sort that out so
you had better look at consequences and
you were better try and look at things
long-term and for a humorous book about
the Antichrist the end of the world and
why we're all going to die we tried to
say you know useful things in there you
know I realized I was for fossil when I
read the other day that in Thailand
they're having a problem with up boobs
selfies a boob selfies of I guess ladies
being photographed looking up that don't
include their faces so the Thai
government is having a real problem
finding who the criminals are that are
doing this now that's a workaround Chris
does have a relevant question here do
you think the internet Facebook Twitter
blogs and so on is helping or hurting
literacy and the quality of writing and
storytelling um I think a lot more
writing is happening yes buta the
Internet and I think that bit is great I
just love the fact that more people are
writing I think the biggest problem that
we have and I think this just applies to
that in the same way that it applies to
everything else is we have gone from a
scarcity based information economy to a
glut information economy in the old days
finding the thing that you needed was
like finding the flower in the desert
you would have to go out into the desert
would find the flower and
it's like finding a flower on the jungle
or worse finding the flower in the
flower gardens so do I think it's
helping do I think it's hurting I think
it's great that people are writing I
think a lot of people are writing who
would not have to have written and did
not expect themselves to be writing but
I also think that thousands upon
thousands upon thousands of people are
writing fiction are writing things that
they simply wouldn't have written
because they wouldn't have been an
audience because there wasn't a way of
getting it out there's more storytelling
in more story reading there's more
storytelling there's more story reading
the task becomes finding the good stuff
for whatever your definition of good
stuff is and your definition of good
stuff might be some horribly specialized
form of Harry Potter /
but it's finding the good stuff out
there in the glut in the jungle and it
it fascinating about Good Omens just now
Good Omens is about a hundred and five
thousand words right as always you know
exactly how many words and there's
probably out there in the world
five million words of Good Omens
fanfiction really oh my god and you sort
of go what about reproducing it's out
there it's the idea of stories getting
out there and just reproducing I love
that I think that that's that's very
strange and very it's a wonderful thing
I don't necessarily know how how things
are gonna work in the world of
publishing story finding story reading
five years from now ten years from now
20 years from now but at least I'm not
pretending that I know I I think weird
things are happening and it's it's
really interesting watching some systems
break and watching other things make
people very very happy see RIF kind of
on your point about Twitter going
sentient you would be the first to know
I think if that happens oh do you have
million and a half to 1 million
followers out there and you know I
suspect that some of them may not exist
in real life
and the reading you instead reproduced
number nina salvador asks much of our
media right now is concerned with the
idea of the emergence of a strong I sent
you Twitter if you were to write this
story how would it go the strong AI
think is the current dark singularity
version story that's going around and so
you know Hawking is scared to death of
it Elon Musk is geared to definitely
would I write it how would it go I don't
I I don't know I do know that I would
write it personally
first make it I would make it small and
personal because that's how I write
stories so you would be Kurt he would be
taking the reader inside the emerging
consciousness of this a eyes much more
likely you know inside the consciousness
of the person who owns the toaster in
which the AI is no story I one of those
things that was when I was a kid reading
science fiction and loving science
fiction I thought you could classify
science fiction into the people who were
obviously writing about the future that
you were traveling into mm-hm there was
there was Asimov there was Heinlein
there was Clark maybe Larry Niven thank
you know these guys who would they could
do the techy stuff and it was all right
and then there was the ones who were
just making it up and wouldn't frankly
weren't even trying like JG Ballard and
and philip k dick
and now I look around and I go now I got
it right dick got it right I'm you know
Heinlein and as more than Clark bless
their little cotton socks got it so
gloriously wrong pretty much completely
you know if you read philip k dick now
and you watch your your toaster arguing
with your fridge yeah I know this this
is this is the world we are heading for
you watch Ballard writing things like
memories of the Space Age or crash you
know a terrifyingly percipient piece of
fiction about the death of lady died
long before she had that's really you
know it's it's like going oh this is
they were there were definitely it was
the ones who I thought we're just making
it up as they went along who actually
were getting the future kind of right
well in there's bill Gibson of course
I'm never sure with Bill how much of it
was just making him making up a future
and I saw going yeah that's cool we'll
go there
James Walter asks he's worried about the
dark side of stories that stay with us
for a long time such as many stories
that blame women for original sin
there's some stories worth forgetting I
think there is an incredible amount of
misogyny and an awful lot of old stories
and and I tend partly because of that to
find myself sympathizing with those
methyl Griffin's and such who go well it
probably started out with women in
charge and having the stories and having
the magic before one day some guy went
well you know they may may be able to do
this amazing baby-making magic and they
may be smarter than us
but we're big and we're hairy so haha we
are we are now going to cast them down
you know and and and we're going to make
up our own stories and religions and in
those we are going to we're going to put
them in their place which idea that one
of the things we're doing now is trying
or some of us are trying to redress that
balance
so genders are occurring story theme
animals are an astonishingly recurring
story mode what's have you do you use
animals you told if I hung around the
cat I mean yes you you have to I don't
believe there's any any there's an
entire website of just authors with cats
and you can tell that they are giving us
all our best ideas I love writing
animals animal but I also think that one
of the things about animals in fiction
is they are your first attempt to put
your head into the other into
experiencing another the idea of another
one thing that I thought about talking
about in that talk and then I thought
you know it's John I'm gonna wander all
over the place probably this is too far
to wander so I didn't but fiction I list
a bunch of things that fiction does and
bunch of things that stories do I don't
talk about probably the most important
thing that I think fiction does which is
it lets us look out through other eyes I
said that but it also gives us empathy
the act of looking out through other
eyes tells us something huge and
important which is that other people
exist that we are not you know it's it's
very very you you you look at some
narratives from some cultures and you go
there is absolutely no empathy here
there is no idea that what you are doing
that that anybody exists as anything
other than a self-motivated thing I
think one of the things that fiction can
give us is just the realization that no
behind every pair of eyes there's
somebody like us and perhaps looking out
through animal eyes there's something
like us looking out through alien eyes
there's somebody like us one of our
speakers in this series was Steven
Pinker who did this book the better
angels of our nature about the basically
perpetual decline and cruelty violence
and injustice and he points to the rise
to the novel in Europe as one of the
sort of turning points where the circle
of empathy was encouraged to get
suddenly wider mm-hmm because we get
inside characters who you would never
meet or talk to in real life but you're
inside their story and so a book comes
along like Uncle Tom's Cabin yeah and
you're inside characters in a
sympathetic frame that you now have to
take their situation seriously in a way
you never did before and a change human
behavior absolutely and and people and
and what's wonderful about that is these
characters were lies they didn't exist
Harriet Beecher Stowe had gonna made-up
people but making up people those made
up people when you've lived with them
and you can care about them you can
suddenly extrapolate you can make the
head jump to real people you live with
them means you're living with them
through a tale through a series of
events situations they have to deal with
and you now are with them trying to
solve the problems that they're facing
exactly so you're you are walking a mile
in their shoes Christopher I was just a
sale so I mean you look at somebody like
Dickens the social novels of Dickens
where Dickens actually for good or ill
wound up when a lot of his novels just
taking social situations that he wanted
to let people know about and in a lot of
cases causing reform real actual social
reform happened people changed their
behavior or institutions were abolished
things were changed because people who
had nothing to do with something or were
content to let it go
suddenly had their noses rubbed in the
Victorian workhouse system in the court
of chancery in the things that he had
problems with in you know the terrible
schools and reformers came from they
came from caring they came from having
traveled with fictional people to whom
terrible things were happening and going
this thing which has happened with these
people that I care about should be
stopped and they and it was stopped it
seems like he did attempted an even more
amazing thing with something like the
Christmas story Scrooge and so on it has
become a mythic level story which is
sort of told at Christmas time again and
again and and the terms of that plot as
a story that everybody now can refer to
do you think you've looked at Dickens
pretty closely
you think Dickens had in mind that he
was going to do a mythic level story and
it had to be short and it had to have a
ghost
and it was going to be this amazing long
now a story of binding past present and
future and he was gonna go deep and
lasting you think that was actually in
his mind where he was just writing a
good yarn I think I think he was writing
a good yarn I think he also discovered
having written it what a good story he
he'd written performed it he did I I
actually performed it at the New York
Public Library dressed as Dickens using
his his copy because Dickens had a he he
worked up a performance version of it
and which cut out anything he didn't
need and the New York Public Library
approached me and they said would you
come in for Christmas and read from
Dickens's prompt coffee the the version
of a Christmas carol that Dickens
performed and I said I will only do it
if you give me dickens gear and at that
and a beard because I didn't have one at
the time so somebody stuck one on and it
was so disappointing I grew this one
mostly in case somebody asked me again I
will have a beard ready but it was
absolutely fascinating for me reading
Dickens his version because this was you
know I was talking about sort of
evolution honing he done it in front of
crowds and in front of crowds and in
front of crowds and he knew what worked
and there was stuff when I read it
through beforehand I was like you've
thrown out some of the most famous lines
you know really that the lines you
expect to have and some of them just be
taken out and you've included the scene
of playing blind man's buff with the fat
cousin why would you have that in there
okay well you've got that in all and
then I performed
and it ran beautifully and just as the
tension got to its highest then we have
the scene a blind man playing blind
man's buff for the fat cousin that
everybody's laughing
this is brilliant he actually he really
did hone this thing in performance but
he also had hit upon this beautiful
structure which then you could take you
could insert almost anything in it be it
Muppets or Blackadder
and it will still work it's like
somebody who built a train you go it's a
train it will work it will work
I've only I think stolen it once but I
remember the point where I woke up and
it was one of those moments of actually
waking up in the night there's a long
time you're 26 27 years ago I had a
phone call from DC Comics my editor at
DC Comics saying you know we'd like you
to write something could you write
something that is a guide to all of the
magical characters in the DC Universe
that also has a story and is interesting
but that well people could buy as a sort
of guide to everything and has a plot
and I said no that's stupid
put down the phone and did that thing
where you are almost asleep and you're
almost almost asleep and then I went oh
hang on I could do a Christmas Carol you
just need past present future only I'd
have to be past present weird fairy
lands and places future yeah I can do
that and I got up and wrote it down
because I knew that it would actually
vanish if I just let it go to sleep and
I did a book books of magic which was me
just ripping off and again it was
ripping off that structure going it
works you have you know you have a
structure I didn't actually need to
reform anybody in that one so when you
perform I mean talk about empathy you
studied their kids you really didn't you
think about Dixie steals from Dickens
and then for one amazing evening you are
Dickens on the stage it was absolutely
fascinating
and it was fascinating for me mostly
because one of the things that have
fascinated me most about Dickens was why
he did these talks why he did public you
know Dickens went on the road and and
would be when all when all over America
doing an evening with Charles Dickens
where he would read selected passages
where he do the whole of this cut down
Christmas Carol and a bunch of other
stuff three hours of Dickens I first
became aware of that when I was about
eleven when a Welsh actor named Emlyn
Williams came to my local theater doing
his version of the evening of Charles
Dickens and I went and loved it and
never forgot that Dickens did this thing
and the reason he did it was that at the
time copyright was broken and his books
he was the best-selling author
America and because copyright didn't
quite work between England and America
his books were all pirated and even make
any money so he went more how can i
monetize being the best-selling author
in America and making no money and he
all people will come and see me and that
absolutely you know he went home rich
and with a solid American audience
having actually taken something that
should have been a huge problem that
that the copyright didn't actually
provide him with the royalty the costume
cost him some of his health I was gonna
say custom significantly in his health
and yet he had that thing writers as
writers seldom have which is the instant
feedback instead of the 14 months later
feedback of the normal book publishing
process and the people are not getting
online and a Twitter writer gets you
know there is still not really feedback
feedback for me is that moment where I
read a short story to an audience and I
hear you know that my favorite moment of
audience feedback ever was in 2008 I had
this mad idea of instead of doing a
signing tour with the graveyard book
there were eight chapters one of which
was twice as long as all of the others
so I would divide that one in half and I
would do nine stops and I would read a
chapter at each stop and I thought that
will be honest or pre-sign a thousand
books or 2,000 books at each place
just like I signed the books out there
this afternoon you but I can sign fast
and I don't mind doing it if it's and
that's that's a quick process it's
stopping and talking to people and you
know hugging people and telling them and
answering their questions that's the
thing that keeps you there till three
o'clock in the morning but the signing
is quick so it's pre-signed a bunch of
books and I do the reading and I hadn't
realized when I thought okay I will just
stop halfway through Chapter seven
that chapter seven has the biggest at
the exact point that I needed to stop on
that page there was the biggest twist
and cliffhanger and of course it's not a
cliffhanger really if you're reading
chapter seven except that I'm in Los
Angeles and I got to that moment in the
story and the audience went and I could
hear two thousand people or going at the
same time which was a feeling of power
that I have never experienced before and
then I closed the book and an entire
audience but oh
and it's great we were filming it you
can actually go online and watch you can
watch me doing it but you can hear the
sound effects that was them that was
power and that was feedback and that was
going okay this thing works and you left
them in hanging and they all went and
bought the book to find out how to turn
down yeah cliff fingers are amazing then
and we all know what a cliff is and what
a hanging off of it actually means
something
Christopher writes you write frequently
about life death and their connection
have your thoughts about death changed
over the course we were working and you
and terry pratchett they've gone round
and round of this and and terry pressure
recently died what's death for you
lately death you know it's interesting
my thoughts about death my feelings
about death have not really changed I
you know I've always regarded death in
some ways as at least for a writer and
emotionally the line from Peter Pan
death will be an awfully big adventure
has always been huge for me as I
remember the the times that I was scared
of dying the time I was most scared of
dying I was three maybe four issues into
Sandman I'd written
I think I'd written four and the first
couple were getting drawn I'd written
the whole of Black Orchid my first
graphic novel which Dave McKean had been
painting Dave was three-quarters the way
through it and
already decided that the artistic style
that he had used in blackhawk it was
simply wrong and was not quite sure
whether it should be buried felt if she
probably shouldn't because he'd done it
but now he needed to move on and do
something else and he gave me all of the
art that he'd done so far to take to DC
Comics on a plane with him and because
he couldn't afford to get it scanned so
I'm on a plane careering I'm going from
England to America on a Pan Am flight
Pan Am flight 5 going to DC and I'm
carrying with me 3/4 a black orchid and
I know that if that plane goes down Dave
is never gonna redraw that stuff
he's already itching to get on with
Arkham Asylum I know that the beginning
of Sandman isn't really very good but
this thing in my head that I think it
can get to is gonna be really good but
I'm gonna have to at least get through
about issue eight where death appears to
get that to work and frankly if I die at
issue 3 DC probably are just going to
dump the thing it's pretty easier so
that flight hmm I did I was just scared
I did the entire flight mentally trying
to hold the plane up scare that if I
took my attention off it maybe it would
crash it was and it was that and I was
absolutely terrified of dying because I
thought if I die right now there's this
really cool and interesting career and
this is life of stuff that I want to do
and it will never happen and nobody will
quite know that I could have been good
and rather peculiarly exactly one week
later to the day Pan Am flight 5
exploded it was it was a I was vaguely
relieved but I you know there was it was
interesting toward the end of Sandman
when I thought actually I would think
die not die if I die now nobody will
know how Sandman would end it'll be like
Edwin Drood would drive them nuts
probably shouldn't I'm but mostly my
attitude towards death is I've done so
much fun stuff I think I've done all of
this great stuff so all this has to do
where you are in the archive and it's ok
to have done about
then death is not such a big deal but
early on and you know soldiers dying in
war almost all young he's interrupted
and it's like it's for me it's all about
potential Terry Terry's death made me a
lot of things made me very sad losing my
friend I had also made me really angry I
remember that and when he was sort of
fading into that what were you angry
about I was angry about a lot of things
I think one of the things I was angry
about angriest about was one of the
things that Terry pointed out when he
announced to the world incredibly
bravely that he had Alzheimer's when he
was he was diagnosed he was you know 59
years old 58 years old diagnosed with
Alzheimer's and he pointed out that for
every 200 dollars spent on cancer
research there's some like three cents
spent on Alzheimer's research except the
possibility that you were going to get
one of these cancers is relatively low
and the probability that you're gonna
get Alzheimer's is relatively high and
but because we regard it as inevitable
we're not trying to fix it and we should
be and didn't he become sort of an
advocate for
[Applause]
voluntary dying assisted dying yes he he
definitely became a a serious advocate
for having the right essentially the
right to choose your own death mm-hmm
the right to go when you want to in a
situation like that in a world like that
and he did it
angrily nobly and then as it happened he
never you know there was a the last time
I I saw him and we talked he rather
proudly confided in me that you know he
had the stuff stuff had arrived
mysterious and it was kept in a secret
place I'm looking at him going Terry you
need help to find your way to the
bathroom at this point you are never
going to find the secret container with
the death pills that you have put in
Sunday the combination thing the secret
stuff but you've stashed you will never
find it you are gonna have to say to rob
your assistant Rob can I have the death
pills now
and Robbie's gonna say no Terry but he
never came to that I must he had some
comfort that it was there even oh I
think I think it gave him enormous
comfort that it was there I think that
was actually what in a strange way
allowed him to face his death with
equanimity you know much as when I gave
up smoking
I kept which was oh well over 30 years
ago now at least for several years there
was a carton of cigarettes in the
freezer just I knew it was there if if I
got up in the middle of the night and
thought right that's it I'm giving up
giving up smoking it would be there and
that carton actually was what allowed me
to give up smoking it was there when I
needed it so I didn't need it
and I think the same with Terry's
mysterious Terry's mystery pills that he
could never actually have found but he
knew they were there something about
options in their maintaining options so
probably the last question you hauled
off and wrote a whole talk for tonight
which thank you this is not just
standing I'm doing a reading or or you
know your standard neil gaiman talking
really thought through this thing and
delivered it having thought through this
thing about how stories last was there
anything that trend up in the research
when thinking of how to tell about it
that surprised you were interested you
were sort of made it worth it for you to
go through the exercise I what's
interesting for me is I'd been we
started talking about me giving this
talk about two years ago two and a half
years ago and so I've spent two and a
half years obsessing the long hard it's
the long time for the long now it's over
now
but the weird thing is then I would
every time I would find the thing like I
think I'm gonna use this in my long now
talk
I would then try it out and so I would I
would tell people things and and go on
follows and they would they would then
give me feedback and I would follow
things up so that actually was lovely
because it kept accreting mm-hmm more
and more information so this was
positively Homeric tonight it was
tonight was was it's like the last time
mm-hmm but I get to say some of this
stuff because this was what it was for
it was for this talk um I think for me
the thing that I really took away from
two-and-a-half years of thinking about
this was an idea that I talked about in
the talk but I don't go as mad as I do
occasionally when I I'm actually you
know in a bar explaining this idea that
that really you can just view people as
this peculiar by-product that stories
used to breed you know really it's the
stories that are the life form they are
older than us they are smarter than us
they keep going but they need human
beings to reproduce much as we need food
or whatever to replay you know we need
we need things to keep ourselves alive
and maybe stories are really are like
viruses but the idea that that
functionally they are symbiotic they
give and they give back and the reason
why people are genuinely I think
addicted to story we need it so much
more than we think we need it
and the reason why story is so important
to us is because it's actually this
thing that we have been using
since the dawn of humanity to become
more than just one person whether you
want to go to the the the Australian
Indigenous people and their stories of
the Dreamtime which are not only stories
of the some lines stories where you
actually get to tell a history that is a
legend that is a myth it is a map and
there is a map mega about 20,000 years
or thirty thousand years ways that
stories of ways that we communicate
important things but the idea that maybe
stories are these things that really are
genuinely symbiotic organisms that we
live with that allow human beings to
advance it's this mad thing that really
did turn up and become very real to me
while I was preparing the talk and which
I kind of throttled back because I
didn't want any of you to think I'm odd
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you